hello welcome to a new edition of
las vegas now in spanish cheers to
natalia bad sound today i want to talk
to you about the concerts coming to las vegas'
this september not only to celebrate
hispanic heritage month but
also mexican independence day
this saturday we will have a couple of
concerts by
regional mexican music artists one of those concerts
is about the band ms had the
privilege of speaking with osvaldo silva
about this and much more osvaldo
thank you very much for giving us a little bit of your
time welcome to the  vegas nao in
spanish to evolve sevilla to all of
you when the opportunity to
greet us public las vegas' happy
I am excited to be with you
and well also anxious to be
full of gas yes we are super anxious
the positive tour is in full swing I was
reading  who have just been at
madison square garden with more than 10,000
attendees,
they have just broken a record with the
song they have c  on becky and snoop
dogg tell us about this whole
experience
well it has really been a
very pleasant experience and now let's see these
events these these venues young josh
like this with this full house of people with
that love of people singing every
song believe me he will come back to us  it is the
soul the new body of what we were
used to doing what we love to be they
have a lot of followers here in
las vegas I know that you are on
tour with my namesake with matar ya jimenez they
have prepared in addition to killing since he
will be here present  suddenly
someone with you on stage
through I am honest there have been two
events that have been the last events
that were a surprise even for
us suddenly seeing that they are on TV and
that they go up on stage is what is
also surprising and I am  Hoping that
gas agendas will also surprise us,
one night of surprises is definitely enough,
but we love it when
no one notifies us when when of  suddenly
we see the artist on stage we
love that we are filled with the
ivac to the public that you can tell your
followers those who will be
present this Saturday at your
concert that you can tell them that they can
wait before those who would like to
thank them for having been taken  the
decision to go to abc continued to make
the redundant decision to
join us in las vegas' that we are going to
do everything possible because everything is
worth it and what they have exposed here
the time they have waited to see a lot
of a month too  We will try to cover all of
this with that performance
and tell them not to let those who
go to dms support us, that many things
we still have in store to show all of
you things will soon begin to
uncover one last question
because it is Las Vegas and here  we see several
artists who have residencies if
port ever comes out same opportunity to
have a residency of the band ms la
guide no of course  Yes, I believe that
we not only think that if there were a day
of opportunity, I believe that it is a desire
for us, there is no power of
resilience.
the ms truck today I am
the spokesperson for them these my
colleagues and others a big hug in
the wishes and bless you always think
very important
the band ms of sergio lizárraga will have
their concert this Saturday
September 11 in friends another ruin inside
the mandalay bay starting  at 9 at
night and there are still tickets available for
this unforgettable night just visit the former
is dotcom well thank you very much for
joining me in this edition of las vegas
nao in Spanish do not forget to visit
disney.com in case you need more
information about  this or other
events see you next time Natalia greets you
bad sound
[Music]